here now with reaction he's the host of
the top rated show on weekends life
liberty and Levin I call him the great
one Mark Levin how many times Mark have
I quoted you as saying that we live in a
post-constitutional America if this is
not a post-constitutional America I
don't know what is
you're 100 correct you know Sean the
Republican party needs to understand
something as do the American people
this massive Federal edifice that's been
built in Washington D.C
works for the Democrat Party it's an
appendage of the Democrat Party
when we have Republican presidents they
sabotage the Republicans they'll
investigate them they'll leak against
them
when we have Democrat presidents you
don't see that kind of behavior in fact
they enlist the massive bureaucracy to
issue regulations and rules and the sick
their political opponents this report
right here the dorm report is actually
very very important because it gives the
official seal to what is the American
stassi at every step of the way this FBI
ignored evidence did not get
corroborating evidence had no evidence
uh did everything it could to protect
Hillary Clinton and did everything it
could to destroy Donald Trump it
falsified information they were told not
to take notes they had no um
basis whatsoever for unleashing their
investigation this country went through
this for over two years it sparked the
Mueller investigation and Donald Trump
is a victim and he's the greatest victim
in American political history and here's
the problem America this same FBI
edifice is in place right now
Christopher Wray is a fool he is a
bureaucrat he uh does not understand
that the constitution puts congressional
oversight ahead of sources and methods
he is just as bad as the guy before him
it's just a disaster what's going on
over there we now have a U.S attorney
dressed up as a special counsel going
after Donald Trump again that document
case didn't have to be criminalized
that's ridiculous to make it to have a
warrant to send down a SWAT team
tomorrow Largo none of that was
necessary that all could have been
negotiated this whole thing about
January 6 in terms of another grand jury
to see if Donald Trump was trying to
prevent the the peaceful transition it's
ridiculous it was Donald Trump who
offered ten thousand armed National
Guard men to protect that building that
should be evidence enough to say you
know what it's ridiculous to be
investigating him so they're not done
and the Republicans on Capitol Hill need
to understand this Administration this
FBI this Department of Justice is
targeting them and they're not going to
submit themselves to oversight so what
do they do well they can litigate it but
they need to do everything they can to
slash the FBI's budget it's too big it
is a massive police state operation it's
like the Stasi they're into everything
and anything they want to be they're in
the Twitter for God's sakes they're
after parents they're after the Catholic
Church they're after pro-lifers the only
thing they're not doing is their damn
job like Prosecuting Democrats who won't
enforce the law on the border and so
forth so I just want to make it
abundantly clear the reason why the
Democrats will fight to the end even
push this country into a depression in a
default is because they need that money
to fund this edifice the federal
government and they won't expand it and
they want to create more programs and
they want to hire more employees 87 000
IRS agents why do you think they want to
hire 87 a thousand IRS agents for good
government note unleash them on the rest
of us
this is the problem that we have right
now in this country and when it comes to
the FBI the FBI is no good it's gone
Rogue it won't even submit to oversight
with a whistleblower who says there's a
document in the FBI that says that Joe
Biden took bribes
that's the president of the United
States for God's sakes now if the
bureaucracy
if it were Donald Trump as president
bureaucracy would leak it right just
like they leaked his tax returns but in
this case you cannot allow a director of
the FBI who's not even in the
Constitution who's not subject to votes
uh by the American people to say I've
got sources and methods yeah we got your
sources and methods here too pal here's
the report and your sources of methods
are corrupt your sources and methods
violate the constitution
and their sources and methods they're
still there the bureaucracy is still
there he says we fixed it all no you
didn't why'd you send a SWAT team to
Mar-A-Lago you didn't fix a damn thing
why are you violating attorney client
privilege by going in front of Obama
judges why are you doing all sorts of
things at the FBI against American
citizens monitoring them keeping files
on them we have the Inspector General
who said they had one million one
million fisa warrants sorry it was an
error what the hell that's crazy so the
FBI needs to be have their budget
slashed it needs to be broken down and
rebuilt and it needs to have uh complete
oversight by the uh by the Congress of
the United and notice one other thing
Sean
the Democrats are perfectly fine
with astasy because it's their Stasi the
New York Times The Washington Post you
know what are they going to do turn back
their pulitzers they're perfectly fine
with the Stasi too it is only we
conservatives anymore who believe in
civil liberties trust me on this it's
true that's it I'm done uh dangerous
times for the country Mark and the sad
part is I'm going to ask you one other
question not only were they not held
accountable for 2016 then the FBI
pre-bunking what they knew was a very
real Hunter Biden laptop in 2020 then
the CIA the the dirty 51 as Miranda
calls them uh we had active employed CIA
agents recruiting former Intel officials
uh when are they going to be held
accountable isn't that putting cinder
blocks on the scale of our elections in
this country
they're never going to be held
accountable because the only entity that
can prosecute them is the one that's
working on this and participating in it
and they are interfering with the 2024
election today with the special counsel
in Washington D.C with these phony
criminal investigations they're
interfering with the election again
today the President Biden it's his FBI
it's his attorney general it's his DA's
they're interfering with the election
the third election in a row there's no
question about it
all right great one Mark Levin don't
forget life liberty live in every Sunday
right here on Fox hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else